pour s'est déroulée normalement c'est à
dire mais j'ai plus ferme à donner aux
bateaux
le maximum
en fonction des conditions défavorables
à 80% v qui m'ont permis la moyenne que
j'avais annoncé au départ une moyenne
justement je les sens et quand l'un pour
nous dire que vous nous aviez dit au
départ que nous vous avions rencontré
pendant que vous vous prépariez vous
mettriez 20 jours
c'est exactement le temps que vous avez
mis un jour une douzaine d'heures elle
inspecte quel petit temps l'arrivée m'a
pas coûté 100 ça j'arrive en moins de 20
heures un multicoque énormément besoin
d'alliés importante et l'art malgré les
vents contraires ont la flemme marché
allemand la préparation a compté
beaucoup
ben écoutez dans des moyennes comme
celle là moi je savais à peu près trois
océans que que je l'espère
justement il y avait la préparation de
l'homme avant celle du bateau et son
équipe il faut former équipe avec le
plateau ce procès c'était aussi un
élément très important nous fait une
course en solitaire à nous parler d'une
équipe
oui parce que derrière derrière bateau
bateau de grandes performances comme
critique à tignes ali à tous ceux qui
ont contribué à sa préparation il ya
tous les techniciens de ce matériel ou
la moindre faille signifie la fin de la
course la fin des espoirs
il faut que tout y est né faut que les
mâles gréements les cordages dévoile
pour que tout soit impeccable sans ça il
ya plus construit cible de l'homme aussi
il faut essayer d'être à la hauteur
ok pour dinard c'est évidemment une voix
particulière puisque c'est à dinard
qu'alain que la préparer le pen du 4 l'a
mis au point s'est entraîné c'est dire
que nos voeux l'ont particulièrement
accompagné que nous nous sommes réjouis
du succès qui vient de remporter
et c'est pourquoi la ville de dinard a
tenu à lui remettre une médaille d'or en
témoignage de reconnaissance son
souvenir
merci le seul ministre à la colla toute
la bretagne et tout l'ouest en général
était je crois avec vous pour cette
course transatlantique
mais maintenant qu allez vous faire dans
un premier temps je vais aller chercher
chercher prennent vie que sa place est
en france et sur la route du retour chez
si les conditions météorologiques le
permettent chez j'ai très envie 35
quelque chose une dernière question vous
l'avais dit la transat c'est un
achèvement alors franchir la ligne en
vainqueur qu'est ce que c'est c'est un
moment un moment où on fond je me suis
retrouvé dans mon cockpit et larmes aux
yeux sont plus rien dans les membres de
ne plus la force d'aller affaler les
voiles
j'ai dû prendre sur moi pour pour
pourvoir 1 évoque l'année la grand voile
et finalement de l'artimon et et autour
de moi je voyais arriver les belettes
pourtant mes amis pourtant les
journalistes et les chalets plus que
sourire et a gardé tout le monde avec un
grand t rv est on est en étau entre
neurones et au au sommet de la montagne
les l'air qu'on y respire elle est
fabuleuse sont des bouffées comporte
toujours au fond du puits